what is a joke a joke in its simplest
form is the setup and defeat of an
expectation you give the audience the
impression that you're about to say
something and then you say something
that they didn't think you were going to
say and when they
experience the new information and gain
a new understanding that's when they
laugh I'll put it in another way a joke
is a puzzle you give to the audience to
solve
and when you give them the right
information in the right way and they
solve the puzzle the solution of the
puzzle presents itself to them in a
tight little package that makes them
laugh see if I can give you an example
there are many I'm not sure what what is
a good one we could go to a a a a light
bulb
joke how many producers does it take to
change a light
bulb well does it have to be a light
bulb funny if you know that producers
are the kind of people who will make
arbitrary bad choices so the truth and
pain of the moment is I'm a writer I got
to deal with producers they don't always
know what they're talking about that's
the truth and pain the joke is
presenting to the audience how many
producers does it take to change a light
bulb well does it have to change what
does that tell me about producers that I
didn't know if I've done my job right
and if the audience has enough
information to solve the puzzle of the
joke then they'll laugh if I'm not sure
that they have enough information to
solve the puzzle of the joke I'll give
them extra information to make sure I
might say to them I went to pitch to
this one producer and he's one of these
guys you know he just never knows what
he wants so I told him a joke I said uh
how many producers did take change a
light bulb and he says wait a minute
does it have to be a light bulb that
will give the audience more
information packed in such a way that
they will arrive at an explosive
solution to the puzzle in the form of a
laugh that's a joke interestingly if you
ask ask AI chat GPT to tell you a joke
its definition of jokes is very narrow
all the jokes have the same structure
why did the X do y because a b or c and
I've done some exploring here and I got
to tell you some of the jokes are okay
but they're not new jokes here's an
example why did the chicken cross the
playground to get to the other
slide not a joke for AI it's kind of a
dad joke it's also a well-known joke AI
didn't invent it but AI will invent a
joke that goes like this why did the
chicken cross the
playground because it wanted its
feathers to get wet or something
completely nonsensical and then that's
hugely amusing to me because I'm like
what was the thought process that
brought this madness to
life I did a standup comedy thing
reading AI jokes and what was funny
about it was not the AI jokes but the
bewilderment of myself and the audience
over how did AI how could AI imagine
that this was funny well it's an
unsolved problem but give it six months
and that problem is going to be much
better solved yeah so that's very true I
think AI understands what is a joke the
way my six-year-old great nephew
understands what is a joke it's not the
same and and also you said the joke sort
of a puzzle but then if you take it too
far then that puzzle doesn't get Sol
exactly if you give the audience too
much information there's no puzzle for
them to solve and a lot of jokes don't
work don't land as they say for this
specific
reason the example that I just gave you
why did the chicken cross the road to
get to the other slide if you've already
heard it it's not funny you already have
too much information there's no puzzle
to solve but a lot of times people who
construct jokes construct them with too
much information and the joke does
doesn't work because the puzzle isn't
hard enough and I tell them this joke
will work you just need to take out some
information subtract some information so
it's not so obvious where you're headed
I'll give you an example of a joke
involving Dwight Eisenhower Richard
Nixon and a construction
worker in the year
1955 when Dwight Eisenhower is
President a construction worker is hit
on the head and goes into a
coma and he wakes up some number of
years
later in
1968 when Richard Dixon is President as
you might know but he looks out the
window he doesn't know he's been asleep
he looks out the window and he sees a
flag flying at half masked and somebody
says he says why is the flag flying at a
half masked and he says he's told oh
President Eisenhower just died and the
guy says oh no that means Nixon is
President see it's funny because he fell
asleep when Nixon was vice president and
woke up when Nixon was president and
didn't know that that had happened and
none of this is funny because you don't
have enough cultural references from the
1960s and how people felt about Richard
Nixon to solve the puzzle of the joke
the way I want you to So In This Moment
here I am profoundly experiencing
failure modeling failure
by giving you a joke I expect you don't
know enough to understand I thought it
was going to be that he woke up and he
saw a flashlight at the Watergate hotel
and and some but I'm taking it from the
from the Forest Gump scene in in the
movie but yes I don't know I wasn't
alive then but but I I didn't some of it
did not land no but I I thought you were
going to there was something about a FL
I was thought that we were going to
Watergate some trust me if I had wanted
to make it funny I'd have made it funny
so
but I wanted to make it not funny I
wanted to show what a joke looks like
when you don't have enough information
to solve the puzzle of the
joke okay right and I and I don't yeah
so here let me try another one okay sure
I this is one I use by example because
sometimes the telling of the joke will
actually give the audience information
that it needs to solve the puzzle of the
joke let me tell you about my friend
Dave and his big ego okay yeah that
sounds good yeah oh Dave Dave and his
big ego now you don't know Dave so if I
tell you I said to Dave the other day
hey Dave you know what I call ego the
little Dave inside me and Dave turns to
me and he says what do you mean little
now you know something about Dave that
you didn't know before and that's an
example of a joke that gives the
audience the information they need to
solve the puzzle of the joke right there
in the punchline when they're solving
the joke and those are the jokes that
tend to work best and you talked about
your friend with the long hair that you
walk dogs with and I didn't know know
him and and you said he he's from
Kentucky yes I have a friend who looks
like uh a mad
scientist and he's from
Kentucky and so I think that for a guy
like him a story involving a mad
scientist in Kentucky would be a good
story but you don't need to know
anything about him except how he looks
in order to see how that class of jokes
will work now let's just imagine that
his his look is wild he got big hairir
it's completely out of control but he
thinks he's the brill cream man he
thinks he's so sophisticated and smooth
doesn't recognize his hair is out of
control so when he goes into a social
situation and he says hey what do you
think of my hair somebody says your hair
scares me to
death he'd be surprised by that it would
confound his
reality now if he went into a social
situation in
1972 his hair would be heroic but but
then the problem might be that he's not
a hippie but everybody thinks he's
hippie because he's got a massive U head
of hair and it might only be that he's
poor and can't afford a haircut it might
be that he sees himself as not a hippie
but he has to conform to everybody
around him so he's wearing his hair long
even if he doesn't feel like a long hair
now again we found an interesting
character a long hair in the 60s and
we've asked ourselves what's interesting
about this guy what's confounding about
this guy what'll give him trouble we've
discovered an interesting inner conflict
he's a long hair who thinks he's a short
hair that's something we can work with
that's a platform we can stand on so the
joke is never about what's happening on
the surface it's always about what's
happening inside the character and what
if some of those people that think he's
a cool hippie they saw him come out of a
meeting room for the young capitalist
Society they would turn against him and
then he would probably realize that he
was in the wrong Camp all
along he probably prob fell in love with
someone who said to him I want to love
you but I can't love your
values and I can't love your values
until your values
change now this is a character who had
no need to change his values until love
God in a way and now has a passionate
need to change and also a passionate
need not to change and that's what
drives the whole story because here's a
character who's got to figure out some
way to be true to himself and meet the
expectations of the person he loves
that's a big challenge a great example
can be found in the movie Tootsie where
Dustin Hoffman is a man playing a woman
and at the end reveals himself to be a
reveals himself to be a man playing a
woman and in that moment in his Moment
of Truth he says to the character I'm
not the person that you thought I was
but I have become the person you need me
to be and that's the moment of truth and
that's when he
wins